all right we've spoken a little bit
before about the Brewing war between
Maga uh suck UPS Marjorie Taylor green
and Lauren bobert both are Republican
members of the House of Representatives
both were re-elected in 2022 Marjorie
Taylor green by a an easy margin Lauren
bobert by the slimmest slimmest slimmest
of margins and increasingly they are at
odds with each other we started seeing
this a couple of weeks ago and I talked
to you about it and now they are
increasingly uh going after each other
in an ugly way which I think we should
support now there are people online
talking about you know cat fight and
sort of uh all this this sort of stuff
that is really not interesting to me the
fact that they are both women
um to me is is not part of why this is
interesting if Madison cawthorne were
still in Congress and he was the one at
odds with bobert or green we would be
just as interested the interesting part
is these cartoonish vapid ignorant
do nothing Maga people
arguing with each other is interesting
because all they really have is their
allegiance to Maga
that's I mean listen if it weren't for
Trump and if it weren't for Maga as
something that they could say we support
they never would have been elected in
the first place and so it's interesting
as we see Trump's 2024 campaign get off
to a shaky start to say the least and we
see questions as to whether or not Maga
will eventually acquiesce and get Kevin
McCarthy elected speaker of the house
it's particularly interesting to see
Maga subdivide and I'm going to go to a
video yesterday we looked at some of
this interview earlier this is the
interview during which Lauren bobert on
Fox News uh told Brett Bayer just like
with George Washington
if we decide Jim Jordan needs to be the
speaker then he will be the speaker she
was presented with some of the things
that Marjorie Taylor green said about
her she then goes after Marjorie Taylor
green it's getting very ugly and Maga
seems to be subdividing let's take a
look you sound bus Marjorie Taylor green
and then Dan Crenshaw tickles please
two million dollars for
money to get elected and then there's a
few of them that don't want to support
him as Speaker
some of the reasons that these people
have for not voting for McCarthy are
unbelievably Petty unbelievably Petty
this is about Showmanship this is about
notoriety it has nothing to do with the
conservative by the way the irony of Dan
Crenshaw saying others are being petty
is not lost on me but it's I don't want
to get derailed because this is more
about Lauren bobert's response which
we're going to see here in a moment
Vegeta Marjory Taylor green
congresswoman saying that you know you
just want a very close election in
Colorado uh and that went to a recount
and she's saying that Kevin McCarthy
helps you get across the Finish Line uh
and that you're just trying to make a
point or make a splash how do you
respond to that well there are laws in
this building that prevent me from going
too far into detail but I can say that I
did not receive any help in that
election and that was a very big deal we
pay dues as members to the nrcc and they
were nowhere to be found and then as far
as
our request being petty I don't think a
secure border is petty I don't think a
term limits bill being brought to the
floor not demanded to pass but brought
to the floor so we actually have an
option to vote on that is petty you're
not saying that your other colleagues
you're not saying your other colleagues
don't want a secure border or don't want
a balanced budget right you're not
saying that about your Republican
colleagues we haven't seen that
demonstrated from leadership we asked
for the RSC the Republican study
committees budget all right you get the
point Lauren bobert saying Marjorie
Taylor green is straight up lying
straight just making it up whole cloth
the support that she received what is
the future of this intramaga spat or
fight I don't have the answer but one of
the things that I expect to happen is As
Trump and if Trump and Maga continue to
look weaker and weaker and part of how
we know this is how are Trump's primary
polls looking including against people
like Ron DeSantis who haven't even
declared that they're running for
anything if Trump looks injured
irreparably I think maybe is the term we
would apply to it I think you will see
more Maga infighting because they will
realize the Trump train the Maga train
on which we even came to power is no
longer going to be the buoy that keeps
us afloat if the allegiance to Maga is
no longer the buoy that keeps us afloat
what else do we need to or can we do to
separate and distinguish ourselves from
the other people who came to power on
the same nothing that we came to power
which was Trump was popular enough at
the time that by endorsing us and us
saying we love Trump we were able to win
if Trump
surges in the polls and re-establishes
himself as the clear guy who's on his
path to win the 2024 Republican
nomination I believe you will see less
of this infighting it is a reflection of
the shakiness and the crumbling nature
of the Trump Maga movement at this point
in time